wer beistand
jeden tag ist
morgen sind immer wieder aufs neue
beginnt
wir sind in den bergen dann bin ich zu
hause aber gleich dass er ganz woanders
wir sind ein abo miniatur wunderland und
da haben uns die welt jetzt mal einen
ganz kleinen
wir sind die ziele mit dem herrscher
danke dass sie sich zeit genommen haben
was sind denn sie hier zuständig mein
aufgabenbereich ist planung der ganzen
landschaft der berge und städte und
dörfer
ok und jetzt schaut man so sagen
kugler direkt einen riesen
kreuzfahrtschiff
wie ein halbes wasser spielt gegen das
ist hier ein ganz legendär das
lokalderby zwischen hals bei unserem
paul ii wie viele zuschauer haben sie
denn daran gesetzt da sitzen derzeit
12.000 fenster sind also 12.000 figuren
diese einzeln eingesetzt haben
da standen genau in dem feld mit zwei
leute und haben zwei zu rücken an rücken
wie figürchen geklebt zwei wochen
anhalten zu tun
es ist ja äußerlich alles wahnsinnig
detailliert nachgebaut auch mit unfällen
aber nicht nur außerhalb der noch in den
häusern selber spielt sich einiges ab
was haben wir hier zum beispiel hier 78
knopfdruck bewegen sich sogar die leute
hier mit ihren maschinen und geräten in
den fenstern kann man dann die
jeweiligen suchen sehen hier sehr
hochzeitssuite und das sind dann die
kleinen ecken wo die besucher dann
suchen und gucken müssen wir sind jetzt
in hamburg wo sind wir genau hier sind
jetzt genau hier eine speicherstadt
exakt hier in dem stoff in diesem
gebäude jetzt kommt dazu
super idee münchen hamburg hier sind
meiner steuerzentrale der welt größten
modelleisenbahn
hier kann man die züge überwachen die
autos und selbst die beleuchtung nachts
wird hier kontrolliert und gesteuert
wir haben alle 15 minuten eine nacht
phase also es wird nicht nur das licht
gedimmt sondern wir gehen auch in blaues
licht über und in der dämmerung abends
und morgens gehen wir in rotes licht
über das ist ganz schwierig und
romantisch
das ist hier die unterirdische
schattenwelt hier warten die züge
ungefähr halbe stunde um dann wieder
raus in den sichtbaren teil zu hören wie
viele züge haben wir fahren hier mit 700
züge über die anlage wow das wird sie
wie viele wir sind hier in der modellbau
werkstatt
hier werden gebaut die figuren in
kleinen szenen und was ist das nächste
große projekt dann hier in dem bereich
entsteht als nächstes italien und dann
möchten wir versuchen so die kultur oder
das leben noch zu zeigen